Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the was nothing that had the faintest lightness to a ship. Only something that might have been the iron scaffolding for the knaves of half a dozen cathedrals laid end to end. Far away, furnaces were smelting thousands and thousands of tons of raw material that finally came to this place in the form of great girders and vast lumps of metal, huge framings, hundreds of miles of stays and rods and straps of steel, thousands of plates, not one of which 20 men could lift unaided, millions of rivets and bolts, all the heaviest and most sinkable things in the world, and still nothing in the shape of a
感谢您收听《历史余味》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 并加入。当时没有任何东西看起来像是一艘船。那更像是把半打大教堂的铁脚手架首尾相连。远处，熔炉正在冶炼成千上万吨的原材料，最终以巨大的梁柱、大块的金属、庞大的框架、数百英里的钢制支撑杆、钢带和钢板的形式运抵此地，其中每一块钢板都不是20个人能独立抬起的，还有数以百万计的铆钉和螺栓，全是世界上最重、最容易下沉的东西，但依然没有呈现出
ship that could float upon the sea. The scaffolding grew higher, and as it grew, the iron branches multiplied and grew with it, higher and higher towards the sky, until it seemed as if man were rearing a temple which would express all he knew of grandeur and sublimity. So that was the Irish journalist Filson Young, a very distinguished journalistic figure in Ireland who covered the Burr War, was also a big admirer of James Joyce, a kind of early enthusiast. But he's probably best remembered for a book he published five weeks after the Titanic sank, called Titanic. And in that brilliant description of the gradual emergence of the Titanic in the Belfast dockyards, he was drawing on first-hand experience because he had been there to see the
一艘能在海上航行的船的形状。脚手架越搭越高，随着它的升高，铁枝杈也随之增多，向着天空不断延伸，仿佛人类正在建造一座能够表达他所知的一切宏伟与崇高的神殿。以上是爱尔兰记者菲尔森·杨（Filson Young）的描述，他是爱尔兰一位非常杰出的新闻人物，曾报道过布尔战争，也是詹姆斯·乔伊斯（James Joyce）的忠实崇拜者，算是早期的狂热粉丝。但他最出名的作品可能是在泰坦尼克号沉没五周后出版的一本书，书名就叫《泰坦尼克号》。在那段关于泰坦尼克号在贝尔法斯特船厂逐渐成形的精彩描述中，他借鉴了第一手经验，因为他曾亲眼目睹了
construction of this, well, Titanic ship in 1911. Very good, Tom. And Dominic, in the first episode, we looked at how the plans for the Titanic, the largest ship ever built, emerged from the rivalry between various capitalists who were investing in the transatlantic route, how the Titanic was built specifically to be not only stupendous in scale, but unbelievably luxurious in terms of its fittings. The most luxurious hotel ever imagined only on the sea. And we were looking at how it was built in the specific context of Belfast in the age of agitation over home rule. And the sense of, well, a terrible beauty being born, one might almost say. Yeah, very good.
1911年这艘，嗯，泰坦尼克号的建造过程。非常好，汤姆。多米尼克，在第一集中，我们探讨了泰坦尼克号——这艘有史以来最大的船——的计划是如何在投资跨大西洋航线的各路资本家之间的竞争中产生的，以及泰坦尼克号是如何被专门建造的，不仅规模宏大，而且在内部装潢上极尽奢华。这是人们能想象到的海上最豪华的酒店。我们还探讨了它是在贝尔法斯特处于“地方自治”运动动荡时期的特定背景下建造的。那种，嗯，一种可怕的美正在诞生，人们几乎可以这样说。是的，非常好。
To adapt Yatesates in this episode we're going to look at how the titanic itself was built how it came to be named how it came to be put on the sea and the thing that struck me in that is how philson young talks about it's made of stuff that sinks yeah you know it's not being made of wood and that of course is going to be very important isn't it in due course it is going to be very important, isn't it, in due course? It is important. But as we will discover, Tom, there's always this suspicion that hangs over the Titanic. I think partly because of what we talked about in the last episode, because it's so obviously
借用叶芝的话，在这一集中，我们将探讨泰坦尼克号本身是如何建造的，它是如何被命名的，它是如何下水的。其中让我印象深刻的是菲尔森·杨谈到它是由会沉没的材料制成的。是的，你知道，它不是用木头做的，这当然在适当的时候会变得非常重要，不是吗？在适当的时候，这确实会变得非常重要，不是吗？这很重要。但正如我们将要发现的，汤姆，泰坦尼克号总是笼罩着一种怀疑。我想部分原因是因为我们在上一集讨论的内容，因为它显然是
the product of kind of late Gilded Age capitalism and competition and so on. There's always this suspicion, well, they must have cut corners. They didn't care about safety, the safety of the passengers. And we'll come on to the question of the lifeboats and all that kind of thing. But I think it's important to say, actually, that a lot of that is just not true. The Titanic, no expenses spared, really, to make the Titanic the most extraordinary ship that has ever been built. And probably, ironically, in many ways, the safest. And Dominic, to this day, you can buy t-shirts in Belfast that have the slogan,
镀金时代末期资本主义和竞争等等的产物。人们总是怀疑，嗯，他们一定偷工减料了。他们不关心安全，不关心乘客的安全。我们稍后会谈到救生艇以及所有这类问题。但我认为必须说明的是，实际上，很多说法都不是真的。泰坦尼克号确实不惜工本，力求将其打造成为有史以来最非凡的船只。而且讽刺的是，在许多方面，它可能也是最安全的。多米尼克，直到今天，你还可以在贝尔法斯特买到印有这样标语的T恤：
Titanic, built by Irishmen, sunk by an Englishman. That's harsh, Tom. Harsh, but true. So yes, it is built by Irishmen. So at the end of the last episode, we talked about the great Harland and Woolf shipyards and its place in the ecosystem of Belfast, this kind of red brick, industrial, smoky, rough, tough, hard city in the north of the island of Ireland. And the man who designs it is a man of Belfast. We haven't talked about him yet, but we talked about Lord Pirrie who runs the shipyard. But the guy who designs it is his nephew. This is a man called Thomas Andrews so andrews is one of these
“泰坦尼克号，由爱尔兰人建造，被英国人沉没。”这太刻薄了，汤姆。刻薄，但却是事实。所以是的，它是爱尔兰人建造的。在上一集结尾，我们谈到了伟大的哈兰德与沃尔夫（Harland and Woolf）造船厂及其在贝尔法斯特生态系统中的地位，这是一个位于爱尔兰岛北部，充满红砖、工业气息、烟雾缭绕、粗犷、强硬的城市。设计它的人是贝尔法斯特人。我们还没谈到他，但我们谈到了经营船厂的皮里勋爵（Lord Pirrie）。但设计它的人是他的侄子。这个人叫托马斯·安德鲁斯（Thomas Andrews），所以安德鲁斯是这些
people there's so many of them in this story who had joined the shipyard as a teenager i think at 16 he was apprenticed for five years that's 1889 and he'd gone through all the different parts of the shipyard so the cabinet makers the shipwright the smiths and so on, finished off with 18 months in the drawing office as a draftsman. And he is the man who designs these ships. And, you know, there's a description of him wearing a bowler hat. You were talking last time, weren't you, about the bowler hats that the foreman would wear? Marker of status and religious identity. Yes, exactly.
人中的一员，这个故事里有很多人都是十几岁就加入了船厂，我想他16岁时就开始了五年的学徒生涯，那是1889年，他经历了船厂的所有不同部门，比如木工、造船工、铁匠等等，最后在绘图室做了18个月的绘图员。他就是设计这些船的人。而且，你知道，有关于他戴着圆顶硬礼帽的描述。你上次谈到了工头会戴的那种圆顶硬礼帽，对吧？那是地位和宗教身份的标志。是的，没错。
Protestant identity and social status. And he would be there, you know, he's ubiquitous in the shipyard, poring over the kind of plans and whatnot, talking to the foreman, talking to the men who are actually going to do, you know, the riveting and the joining and all of these different things. And what Andrew specializes in is big, beautiful, very luxurious, frankly, very safe ships. So Cunard are famous for speed, and they will sacrifice anything for speed. They want to get, what is it, the Blue Ribbons?
新教身份和社会地位。他会出现在那里，你知道，他在船厂无处不在，钻研各种图纸之类的东西，与工头交谈，与那些真正要进行铆接、连接以及所有这些不同工作的人交谈。安德鲁斯擅长的是建造大型、美观、非常豪华，坦率地说，非常安全的船只。卡纳德航运公司（Cunard）以速度闻名，他们会为了速度牺牲一切。他们想要得到什么来着？“蓝丝带”奖？
The Blue Ribbons, yeah. The record for crossing the Atlantic quickly. White Star don't bother competing with that. Andrews doesn't make that kind of ship. So in 1911, they had launched Olympic, which is the first one of this kind of class. These three ships that are going to recapture the Atlantic market from Cunard and from the Germans. An Olympic, which is an Andrews design, is slower than the Cunard. It's bigger, but it is to go on it. You're transported into another world. So there's a wonderful description by a guy called Lord Winterton, who crossed from New York on the Olympic in 1912. And he wrote in his diary, she really is a fine ship, exceeds one's imagination. Rackets caught, gymnasium, swimming bath, restaurant, public rooms are splendid.
“蓝丝带”，是的。横渡大西洋的最快纪录。白星航运公司（White Star）不屑于与之竞争。安德鲁斯不造那种船。所以在1911年，他们下水了奥林匹克号（Olympic），这是该级别船只的第一艘。这三艘船将从卡纳德和德国人手中夺回大西洋市场。奥林匹克号是安德鲁斯的设计，比卡纳德的船慢。它更大，但当你登上它时，你会被带入另一个世界。温特顿勋爵（Lord Winterton）曾于1912年乘坐奥林匹克号从纽约横渡大西洋，他写下了一段精彩的描述。他在日记中写道：它确实是一艘好船，超出了人们的想象。壁球场、健身房、游泳池、餐厅、公共房间都非常华丽。
The thing he really likes, he says, there's no shippy smell. Anyone who's been on a cross channel ferry will know what a shippy smell is oh i see yeah ferry yeah yeah that's generally the smell of people being sick and stuff isn't it tom i mean well exactly i mean that is a part of it isn't it yes i guess so you don't get sick on the titanic no you don't no you don't so thomas andrews had traveled with bruce Ismay, the owner of White Star. So they went on the Virgin Voyager, didn't they? Of the Olympic.
他真正喜欢的一点是，他说，船上没有那种“船味”。任何坐过跨海渡轮的人都知道什么是“船味”。哦，我明白了，是的，渡轮，是的，是的，那通常是人们晕船之类的味道，对吧，汤姆？我的意思是，嗯，完全正确，我的意思是那是其中的一部分，不是吗？是的，我想是这样。你在泰坦尼克号上不会晕船。不，你不会。不，你不会。所以托马斯·安德鲁斯曾与白星航运的老板布鲁斯·伊斯梅（Bruce Ismay）同行。他们乘坐的是处女航，对吧？奥林匹克号的。
And Ismay is busy taking notes, ready for the Titanic. And so he goes into the crew's galley and he notices that they don't have potato peelers. So he wants to change that. He goes into the toilets and he notices there aren't cigarette holders. And so he wants to change that. He goes into the toilets and he notices there aren't cigarette holders. And so he wants to change that for the Titanic. He thinks that the reception room should have more tables, more cane chairs, and he tests the mattresses and he thinks they're too springy. So very, very close attention to detail with the aim of making the Titanic just that much better, even than the Olympic. Yes. So a lot of the things you're describing are for the first class passengers. So obviously the first class passengers are going to generate a huge amount of income for the company. And one of the things that Ismay says is the Olympic's great,
伊斯梅忙着做笔记，为泰坦尼克号做准备。他走进船员厨房，注意到他们没有土豆削皮机。所以他想改变这一点。他走进厕所，注意到没有烟灰缸。所以他想改变这一点。他走进厕所，注意到没有烟灰缸。所以他想为泰坦尼克号改变这一点。他认为接待室应该有更多的桌子、更多的藤椅，他测试了床垫，觉得它们太有弹性了。所以他非常、非常关注细节，目标是让泰坦尼克号比奥林匹克号还要好一点。是的。所以你描述的很多东西都是针对头等舱乘客的。显然，头等舱乘客将为公司带来巨大的收入。伊斯梅说的一件事是，奥林匹克号很棒，
but when we do the Titanic, I think we should fit in even more cabins on the top deck. And he says, let's have some really, really super duper first class suites. So they put in two extraordinary suites that have two bedrooms, a sitting room, servants' quarters, and their own little promenade deck that you can step out. So your own private sort of balcony. And this is the suite that is being built with Morgan in mind. Yeah. JP Morgan, who we talked about last time. Yeah. Because obviously Morgan ultimately is bankrolling the whole thing. Exactly. And so they're building it with the richest man in the world at the back of their mind. And the price tag. So the price tag would be for the height of the season, they are going to charge £870 a trip.
但当我们建造泰坦尼克号时，我想我们应该在顶层甲板多装一些客舱。他说，让我们搞一些真正超级豪华的头等舱套房。于是他们安装了两个非凡的套房，有两个卧室、一个起居室、仆人房，还有他们自己的小散步甲板，你可以走出去。所以是你自己的私人阳台。这就是以摩根（Morgan）为蓝本建造的套房。是的，J.P.摩根，我们上次谈到过他。是的，因为显然摩根最终是整个项目的金主。没错。所以他们建造时心里想的是世界上最富有的人。还有价格标签。所以价格标签是，在旺季，他们每趟收费870英镑。
So I've worked out what that is. There's a website called Measuring Worth, brilliant website done by academics, because it's very hard to compare values then and now. But those sweets, Tom, would cost you £400,000 in today's money at the height of the season. So in other words, they are for billionaires. They're astronomically rich, not just quite rich, but people who are astronomically rich. But Dominic, the intriguing thing about this, that obviously we have immediately focused in on the accommodation for the first class passengers because the display of incredible luxury is always a source of fascination. But there is a truth about Titanic and her sister
我算了一下那相当于多少钱。有一个叫“Measuring Worth”的网站，是一个由学者做的很棒的网站，因为很难比较当时和现在的价值。但汤姆，那些套房在旺季相当于今天的40万英镑。换句话说，它们是为亿万富翁准备的。他们是天文数字般的富有，不仅仅是很有钱，而是天文数字般的富有。但多米尼克，关于这一点有趣的是，我们显然立即关注了头等舱乘客的住宿，因为对令人难以置信的奢华的展示总是令人着迷。但关于泰坦尼克号和她的姐妹
ships that is often buried. And it's brilliantly summed up by Frances Wilson in her wonderful book about J. Bruce Ismay, How to Survive the Titanic, where she writes, the Titanic was only superficially a liner for the rich. She was actually an emigrant ship. Yeah. And so that is a crucial part of why the Titanic is so large, isn't it? It is, because they're going to pack onto it hundreds and hundreds of people who are not paying 870 pounds, the equivalent of almost half a million pounds today, but are second and third class passengers. Now, what a lot of people listen to this podcast will probably assume straight away is, oh, this is a story of the rich and the poor. The rich are in great comfort. Nobody cares about the poor. They're kind of locked into their cells below decks.
船，有一个事实经常被掩盖。弗朗西斯·威尔逊（Frances Wilson）在她关于J.布鲁斯·伊斯梅的精彩著作《如何从泰坦尼克号中幸存》（How to Survive the Titanic）中对此做了精彩的总结，她写道：泰坦尼克号表面上只是一艘为富人准备的邮轮。她实际上是一艘移民船。是的，所以这就是为什么泰坦尼克号如此巨大的关键部分，对吧？确实如此，因为他们要在上面塞进成百上千的人，这些人支付的不是870英镑——相当于今天近50万英镑——而是二等和三等舱的乘客。现在，很多听这个播客的人可能会立刻认为，哦，这是一个关于富人和穷人的故事。富人享受着极大的舒适。没人关心穷人。他们被锁在甲板下的牢房里。
Rats, bilge water, all that. Yeah, but this is just not right. This is not the case. Facilities for second and third class passengers on White Star liners are better than they are on any other competing liners. And they are better on the Titanic than they are on any other ship in history. So to be a third-class passenger, you would much rather be in the Titanic. And we will come to the experience of the passengers later, what they eat, what they do. But just to anticipate,
老鼠、舱底水，诸如此类。是的，但这根本不对。这不是事实。白星航运邮轮上二等和三等舱乘客的设施比任何其他竞争对手的邮轮都要好。而且它们在泰坦尼克号上比历史上任何其他船只都要好。所以作为三等舱乘客，你宁愿在泰坦尼克号上。我们稍后会谈到乘客的体验，他们吃什么，做什么。但先预告一下，
I think it's fair to say of the third-class passengers that, ironically, the days they spent on the Titanic, for many of them, were the best days they'd ever spent in their lives. Until obviously the last two hours. Yes. Pretty bad ending. Yeah. But up till then, brilliant. But they are in, by the standards that they're used to, tremendous comfort. They have more spacious accommodation. They have better facilities.
我认为可以公平地说，对于三等舱乘客来说，讽刺的是，他们在泰坦尼克号上度过的日子，对他们中的许多人来说，是他们一生中度过的最好的日子。当然，最后两个小时除外。是的，结局很糟糕。是的。但在那之前，非常棒。但按照他们习惯的标准，他们处于极大的舒适之中。他们有更宽敞的住宿。他们有更好的设施。
They have better food. They have area. They're better lit. All of these kinds of things. They're determined that the Titanic will be the best in every department, not just the first class cabins. taken to the seas and the stats are designed to be overwhelming so it's a sixth of a mile long yeah so 882 feet 92 feet wide and uh it's decks i mean it's kind of the equivalent of an 11-story building so anyone who's seen the james cameron film this is brilliantly evoked with the lifeboats going down i mean you just get the sense of how high this is. I mean, it's designed to be Titanic, isn't it? It is indeed. That's the whole point. It is. Tom, have you ever been on an ocean liner?
他们有更好的食物。他们有活动区域。光线更好。所有这些东西。他们决心让泰坦尼克号在每个部门都做到最好，不仅仅是头等舱。它驶向大海，各项数据设计得令人震撼，它有六分之一英里长，是的，882英尺长，92英尺宽，而且它的甲板，我的意思是，它相当于一座11层高的建筑，所以任何看过詹姆斯·卡梅隆电影的人，都会被救生艇放下的场景所震撼，我的意思是，你真的能感觉到它有多高。我的意思是，它被设计成“泰坦尼克”式的，不是吗？确实如此。这就是重点。是的。汤姆，你坐过远洋邮轮吗？
I have once, yes. My mother was desperate to go on a cruise and so I got a chance to go and lecture on a cruise ship. I hated it. Did you? There was definitely a shippy smell on that, I can tell you. I went on the QM2. So lecturing again. Queen Mary. Yeah, the Queen Mary. So that was about, what was that? 15 years ago or something. I have to say I didn't massively enjoy it either. And that was from Southampton to New York. So it was the Titanic's route. Did you get seasick? I didn't get seasick. I got bored
我坐过一次，是的。我母亲非常渴望去游轮旅行，所以我得到了一个在游轮上做讲座的机会。我讨厌它。是吗？我告诉你，上面确实有一种“船味”。我坐的是玛丽皇后2号（QM2）。所以又是去讲座。玛丽皇后号。是的，玛丽皇后号。那是大约，那是什么时候？15年前左右吧。我必须说我也没有特别享受。那是从南安普敦到纽约。所以那是泰坦尼克号的路线。你晕船了吗？我没晕船。我感到无聊，
because you're there for kind of four or five days. There's nothing to see in the middle of the Atlantic. The one thing I will say, the experience of sailing into New York at dawn is incredible. You sort of sail in, it's five o'clock in the morning, everybody's got up there on the decks. You're looking out, you see the Statue of Liberty, you see the bridges. That is amazing. Anyway, that's by the by. But the thing about that is it's a slightly retro experience, isn't it? Yeah, it is, which is not at the time. That is the point, which of course, for people sailing on the Titanic or sister ships, the whole point is the modernity. Totally. Electricity.
因为你在那里待了四五天。在大西洋中部什么也看不到。我唯一要说的是，在黎明时分驶入纽约的体验是不可思议的。你驶入港口，那是早上五点钟，每个人都起床到了甲板上。你向外看，你看到自由女神像，你看到桥梁。那太棒了。总之，那是题外话。但关于这一点，这是一种稍微复古的体验，不是吗？是的，确实，但在当时并非如此。这就是重点，当然，对于乘坐泰坦尼克号或其姐妹船的人来说，重点就是现代性。完全是。电力。
Electricity, yes. Marconi wireless stations. So you can send Marconi grams, can't you? So it's equivalent to being able to email someone. Yeah. It would now be, you're doing Zoom calls. They've got a special Zoom room on the ship or something. They have huge fridges powered by electricity. So people marveled at the food later on. We might come to this. One of the British aristocrats says, oh my gosh, strawberries in the middle of the Atlantic. This is the height of luxury. That's all possible because of the modernity of the ship. As you say, there's no retro feel about it to these people. They are living in the future as they see it. A question on the name Titanic. We've mentioned before how J.P. Morgan is described as a Titanic figure. Maybe that's floating behind it. Obviously, it's an allusion to its size. There is something hubristic about it, isn't there? I mean, the Titans are the gods who ruled the world before Zeus and his generation
电力，是的。马可尼无线电台。所以你可以发送马可尼电报，对吧？所以这相当于可以给某人发电子邮件。是的。现在这就相当于在进行Zoom通话。他们在船上有专门的Zoom房间之类的。他们有巨大的电力驱动冰箱。所以人们后来对食物赞叹不已。我们可能会谈到这一点。一位英国贵族说，天哪，大西洋中部竟然有草莓。这是奢华的巅峰。这一切都是因为船的现代性才成为可能。正如你所说，对这些人来说，它没有复古的感觉。他们正如他们所见，生活在未来。关于“泰坦尼克”这个名字的问题。我们之前提到过J.P.摩根被描述为一个泰坦尼克式的人物。也许这背后有某种暗示。显然，这是对其规模的影射。这其中有一种傲慢，不是吗？我的意思是，泰坦尼（Titans）是在宙斯和他的那一代
of Greek gods emerged and were overthrown. I just wonder whether there was ever any sense that perhaps it was asking for trouble to name a ship Titanic. I wouldn't have said so because it could have been the Olympic that hit the iceberg. And in that case, wouldn't you be telling the same story and saying the hubris of comparing yourself with the Olympians? Or an even better metaphor, Tom, if it had been the Britannic that had hit the iceberg? Well, Britannic, yes, would have been very sad. But Olympic and Titanic, I mean, the Olympians are the guys who survive and the Titans are the one who end up kind of in chains at the bottom of the world.
希腊神话中的众神出现并推翻他们之前统治世界的众神。我只是想知道，是否有人觉得给一艘船命名为“泰坦尼克号”是在自找麻烦。我不会这么说，因为撞上冰山的是奥林匹克号也未可知。那样的话，你难道不会讲同样的故事，说把自己比作奥林匹亚众神是一种傲慢吗？或者一个更好的比喻，汤姆，如果撞上冰山的是不列颠号（Britannic）呢？嗯，不列颠号，是的，那会非常令人难过。但奥林匹克号和泰坦尼克号，我的意思是，奥林匹亚众神是幸存者，而泰坦尼（Titans）是最终被锁在世界底部的那群人。
I mean, so Churchill's very keen on the name, isn't he? Yes, Churchill loves the name. He uses it a lot. He says, we have arrived at a new time. Let us realize it. And with that new time, strange methods, huge forces, larger combinations, a Titanic world have sprung up around us. And that kind of, we talked in the last episode about the grandiosity of the Edwardians.
我的意思是，丘吉尔非常喜欢这个名字，不是吗？是的，丘吉尔喜欢这个名字。他经常使用它。他说，我们已经进入了一个新时代。让我们意识到这一点。随着那个新时代，奇怪的方法、巨大的力量、更大的组合，一个泰坦尼克式的世界在我们周围涌现。那种，我们在上一集谈到了爱德华时代的宏大。
They are conscious that they are standing on the shoulders of their Victorian fathers and mothers, but there is a sort of an obsession with size and grandeur. Do you not think in kind of the 1900s? But I also think that that is why the story of the titanic has the resonance that it does i think if it hadn't been called the titanic i mean if it had been the olympic or even if it had been the britannic it wouldn't have the kind of global resonance that it has i do think the name is yeah kind of incredibly important and it's a conscious kind of grasping after greatness isn't it it? Definitely it is. Also, it's seen, I think, as being the embodiment of, I mean, Anglo-Saxon. They're very keen on the idea of the Anglo-Saxon race.
他们意识到自己站在维多利亚时代的父辈和母辈的肩膀上，但有一种对规模和宏大的痴迷。你不觉得在1900年代是这样吗？但我同时也认为，这就是为什么泰坦尼克号的故事具有如此共鸣的原因。我想如果它不叫泰坦尼克号，我的意思是如果它是奥林匹克号，或者即使它是不列颠号，它也不会有现在这种全球性的共鸣。我确实认为这个名字，是的，非常重要，这是一种对伟大的自觉追求，不是吗？绝对是。此外，我认为它被视为，我的意思是，盎格鲁-撒克逊人的化身。他们非常热衷于盎格鲁-撒克逊种族的理念。
Again, a very Edwardian, you know, Kipling. Kipling's always going on about the Anglo-Saxons. Yeah. The owners, White Star, they say explicitly, the Olympic and the Titanic are not only the largest vessels in the world, they represent the highest attainments in naval architecture and marine engineering they stand for the preeminence of the anglo-saxon race on the ocean so people can hardly be surprised when later on they treat it as a metaphor yeah because they have deliberately courted that haven't they so the idea of design
同样，非常爱德华时代，你知道，吉卜林（Kipling）。吉卜林总是谈论盎格鲁-撒克逊人。是的。船主白星航运明确表示，奥林匹克号和泰坦尼克号不仅是世界上最大的船只，它们代表了海军建筑和海洋工程的最高成就，它们代表了盎格鲁-撒克逊种族在海洋上的卓越地位。所以当后来人们把它当作一个隐喻时，人们几乎不会感到惊讶。是的，因为他们已经刻意追求了这一点，不是吗？所以设计的理念，
it's not just about the luxury it's not just about the size it's also about the design we talked about thomas andrews who in the james cameron film you know he's in just about the luxury. It's not just about the size. It's also about the design. We talked about Thomas Andrews, who in the James Cameron film, he's in a way the conscience of the ship in absolute despair when he realises that he hasn't built in enough safety features, as it were. Now, regular listeners to this podcast will know there is nothing we enjoy more than explaining naval technology to people. Isn't that right, Dominic? I love it, Tom. I love it. So I know that this is a topic that you're particularly interested in. So I'm just going to sit back and listen to you explain why actually-
不仅仅是关于奢华，不仅仅是关于规模，它也关于设计。我们谈到了托马斯·安德鲁斯，他在詹姆斯·卡梅隆的电影中，你知道，他不仅仅是关于奢华。不仅仅是关于规模。它也关于设计。我们谈到了托马斯·安德鲁斯，他在詹姆斯·卡梅隆的电影中，在某种程度上是这艘船的良心，当他意识到他没有内置足够的安全功能时，他陷入了绝望。现在，这个播客的常客会知道，没有什么比向人们解释海军技术更让我们享受的了。对吧，多米尼克？我喜欢，汤姆。我喜欢。所以我知道这是一个你特别感兴趣的话题。所以我只是要坐下来听你解释为什么实际上——
Total cowardice on your part. The Titanic is famously described as unsinkable. Why do people think it's unsinkable? Right. What are the features that Andrews has put in? Okay. I'm very happy to do this. I'm prepped for it, Tom. Take it away. Because people listening to this podcast will know, of course, the Titanic sank, and therefore they will say, well, terribly flawed, hubristic, all the rest of it.
你真是个彻头彻尾的懦夫。泰坦尼克号被誉为“永不沉没”。为什么人们认为它永不沉没？对。安德鲁斯加入了哪些功能？好的。我很高兴这样做。我为它做了准备，汤姆。开始吧。因为听这个播客的人会知道，当然，泰坦尼克号沉没了，因此他们会说，非常糟糕，傲慢，诸如此类。
I think it's important to stress, as counterintuitive as it sounds, that the Titanic probably has the best safety features of any ship ever built up to this point. So Harland and Wolfe, the ship builders, Thomas Andrews, the designer, thought quite carefully about this. First of all, they've given it a double bottom in case it runs aground. So that is a problem sometimes for ships.
我认为重要的是要强调，尽管听起来有悖常理，但泰坦尼克号可能拥有当时建造的任何船只中最好的安全功能。所以哈兰德与沃尔夫造船厂，造船商，设计师托马斯·安德鲁斯，对此进行了相当仔细的思考。首先，他们给它安装了一个双层底，以防它搁浅。所以这对船只来说有时是个问题。
You know, they end up on shoals or something. And so they have put two sets of steel plates so that if the keel is penetrated by running aground on rocks. I love it when you talk nautically. That is a sinister, that's a sinister moment. So if the first set of steel plates is broken, the second will still be intact. So that's number one.
你知道，它们最终会搁浅在浅滩上之类的。所以他们安装了两层钢板，这样如果龙骨因为搁浅在岩石上而被刺穿。我喜欢你谈论航海术语的样子。那是一个险恶的，那是一个险恶的时刻。所以如果第一层钢板破裂，第二层仍然会完好无损。所以这是第一点。
Now, the other thing that might happen, of course, is it might run into something. An iceberg, for instance. An iceberg, or a ship might run into the side of it. So those are the other two perils that await you on the sea. And they have thought about this as well. Now, unlike any other ship ever built, the Titanic has been built with 15 bulkheads. Imagine them as vertical lines drawn down the ship. They divide the ship into 16 compartments, all of which are watertight. And they have doors that can be shut automatically.
现在，当然可能发生的另一件事是它可能会撞上什么东西。比如冰山。冰山，或者另一艘船可能会撞上它的侧面。所以这些是你在海上等待的其他两个危险。他们也考虑到了这一点。现在，与以往建造的任何其他船只不同，泰坦尼克号建造了15个舱壁。把它们想象成在船上画的垂直线。它们将船分成16个水密隔舱。它们有可以自动关闭的门。
The Titanic has been designed such that if the front four compartments are totally flooded, it will not sink. So in other words, if it hits something straight on. Equally, if a ship crashes into it in the middle, if two of the central compartments are flooded, again, it still won't sink. There is, however, Tom, I know we love a classical reference. Is there an Achilles heel, Tom? There is an Achilles heel. so the bulkheads are very expensive these are state-of-the-art things and the designers have concluded that the chances of you being hit such that more compartments than that are flooded is so unlikely the bulkheads don't
泰坦尼克号的设计使得如果前四个隔舱完全进水，它也不会沉没。换句话说，如果它正面撞上什么东西。同样，如果一艘船在中间撞上它，如果两个中央隔舱进水，同样，它也不会沉没。然而，汤姆，我知道我们喜欢古典引用。有没有阿喀琉斯之踵（Achilles heel），汤姆？有一个阿喀琉斯之踵。所以舱壁非常昂贵，这些是顶尖的东西，设计师们得出结论，你被撞击导致超过那个数量的隔舱进水的几率太小了，舱壁不需要
need to reach up right to the very top as it were so So in some places, the bulkheads are only about 15 feet higher than the waterline. So the height, more than two men. So in other words, if the front six compartments of the Titanic are flooded, not the front four, but the front six, then the water will rise up over the top of the bulkheads and they'll go into the next compartment. And once they fill that compartment, then they go over and then it will start to tip and it'll go over into the ones at the back. Now, they don't even really consider that as a possibility. It is so unlikely that that would happen because if you ram into an iceberg, let's say, I mean, that does happen. And generally you don't sink. Yeah. You know, it's fine, I mean, that does happen. And generally you don't sink.
一直延伸到最顶部。所以，在某些地方，舱壁只比水线高出约15英尺。所以高度，超过两个人的高度。换句话说，如果泰坦尼克号的前六个隔舱进水，不是前四个，而是前六个，那么水就会漫过舱壁顶部，进入下一个隔舱。一旦它们填满了那个隔舱，它们就会漫过去，然后船就会开始倾斜，水会漫进后面的隔舱。现在，他们甚至没有真正把那当作一种可能性。这种情况发生的可能性太小了，因为如果你撞上冰山，比如说，我的意思是，那确实会发生。而且通常你不会沉没。是的。你知道，没关系，我的意思是，那确实会发生。而且通常你不会沉没。
Yeah. You know, it's, it's fine. You can do that. And actually people often say, if there's an iceberg coming straight at you, the safest thing you can do is to keep going. It's just to ram it. It's just to ram it. Okay. But let's imagine, I mean, they still have to think the unthinkable. They have to think what happens if you do have to abandon ship lifeboats. And the famous thing that again i imagine most people listening to this will know is that there weren't enough lifeboats does this reflect a reckless lack of safety consciousness on the part of the builders or is it more complicated than that dominic it is more complicated tom we should be sponsored by white star do they still
是的。你知道，没关系。你可以那样做。实际上人们常说，如果有冰山迎面而来，你能做的最安全的事情就是继续前进。就是直接撞上去。就是直接撞上去。好的。但让我们想象一下，我的意思是，他们仍然必须考虑不可想象的事情。他们必须考虑如果你确实不得不弃船，救生艇该怎么办。而著名的、我想大多数听众都会知道的事情是，救生艇不够多。这是否反映了建造者在安全意识上的鲁莽缺失，还是比这更复杂，多米尼克？这更复杂，汤姆。我们应该由白星航运赞助，他们还
exist because i don't want to sound like we're total apologists for White Star, but it is much more complicated than that. So Peary goes to a meeting with the general manager of Harland & Wolfe, Thomas Andrews, the designer, and they talk about the lifeboats. Now, government regulations are very lax when it comes to lifeboats. The government regulations allow for about 20 lifeboats, and they've got plans because they think the government are going to beef up their regulations.
存在吗？因为我不想听起来我们是白星航运的彻头彻尾的辩护者，但这要复杂得多。所以皮里去和哈兰德与沃尔夫的总经理、设计师托马斯·安德鲁斯开会，他们谈到了救生艇。现在，政府在救生艇方面的规定非常宽松。政府规定允许大约20艘救生艇，他们有计划，因为他们认为政府会加强规定。
So they have plans for 48 lifeboats, maybe even 64 lifeboats and they've got plans because they think the government are going to beef up their regulations so they have plans for 48 lifeboats maybe even 64 lifeboats but actually they talk about it and it becomes clear that the government are not going to introduce these new regulations as quickly as they thought so there's no pressure to increase the number of lifeboats and they say well you know the lifeboats create a lot of clutter on the deck. They cut down on the amount of facilities that we're able to offer. And of course, luxury is our thing. Luxury in space and airiness. Yeah. So we'll just go with the 20 or so lifeboats.
所以他们有48艘救生艇的计划，甚至可能是64艘救生艇，他们有计划，因为他们认为政府会加强规定，所以他们有48艘救生艇的计划，甚至可能是64艘救生艇，但实际上他们讨论了这个问题，很明显政府不会像他们想象的那样迅速引入这些新规定，所以没有压力去增加救生艇的数量，他们说，嗯，你知道，救生艇在甲板上造成了很多杂乱。它们减少了我们能够提供的设施数量。当然，奢华是我们的卖点。空间和空气感的奢华。是的。所以我们就用那20艘左右的救生艇吧。
What that means, as you rightly say, is they only have lifeboat space, therefore, for one third of their passengers and their crew. So to be precise, they have 14 wooden lifeboats that can carry 65 people each. They have two kind of collapsible boats that can take 47 people each. And they have two little cutters that they can sort of shoot off to collect people who've fallen overboard. They can take 40 people each and they have two little cutters that they can sort of shoot off to collect people who have fallen overboard. They can take 40 people each. What that means is there are almost 2,400 people for whom there are no places. And so Dominic, that is a huge part of the kind of the metaphorical potency of the story. So in Frances Wilson's wonderful book on Ismay, she writes, instead of lifeboats, the patrons had luxury,
这意味着，正如你正确指出的，他们因此只有三分之一的乘客和船员的救生艇空间。所以准确地说，他们有14艘木制救生艇，每艘可搭载65人。他们有两艘可以折叠的船，每艘可搭载47人。他们还有两艘小快艇，可以放下去收集落水的人，每艘可搭载40人，他们还有两艘小快艇，可以放下去收集落水的人，每艘可搭载40人。这意味着有近2400人没有位置。所以多米尼克，这是这个故事隐喻力量的巨大组成部分。所以弗朗西斯·威尔逊在关于伊斯梅的精彩著作中写道，乘客们得到的不是救生艇，而是奢华，
a palm court, a gymnasium, and a Louis XVI restaurant. So there seems to be a very obvious moral point being made there, except that I hadn't realised that that imbalance, the fact that you'd only have kind of lifeboat space for a third, by the standards of the time, that's very impressive. I mean, that's unusually good. Yeah, I think that quote is too harsh. That Francis Wilson line implies that they're recklessly dispensing with safety standards to pander to the rich.
棕榈庭院、健身房和路易十六风格的餐厅。所以这似乎是一个非常明显的道德观点，除了我没有意识到那种不平衡，即你只有三分之一的救生艇空间，按照当时的水平，这非常令人印象深刻。我的意思是，这异常地好。是的，我认为那句话太刻薄了。弗朗西斯·威尔逊的那句话暗示他们鲁莽地放弃了安全标准来迎合富人。
In their minds, they are the height of health and safety. I know that will sound mad to 99% of our listeners because they will say, how could that possibly be the case? 2,400 people have no lifeboat. But exactly that, when you look at other companies, other liners, so the Lusitania, for example, has a deficiency of 2,000 people. The German liners, the Hamburg America and the Norddeutsche liners, they have a deficiency of more than 2,000. In fact, Norddeutsche Lloyd's George Washington ship has a deficiency of 2,752 spaces.
在他们看来，他们是健康和安全的巅峰。我知道这对我们99%的听众来说听起来很疯狂，因为他们会说，怎么可能呢？2400人没有救生艇。但恰恰如此，当你看看其他公司、其他邮轮时，比如卢西塔尼亚号（Lusitania），它有2000人的缺口。德国邮轮，汉堡-美洲航运公司（Hamburg America）和北德意志航运公司（Norddeutsche），它们的缺口超过2000人。事实上，北德意志航运的乔治华盛顿号（George Washington）有2752个空间的缺口。
And actually the worst of all, Tom, the one people you don't want to travel with, the Dutch. No. Holland America, their Rotterdam liner, has a deficiency of 3,000 places. I mean, you definitely don't want to travel across the Atlantic on a Dutch ship.
而且最糟糕的是，汤姆，你最不想与之同行的人，荷兰人。不。荷兰美洲航运公司（Holland America），他们的鹿特丹号（Rotterdam）邮轮有3000个空间的缺口。我的意思是，你绝对不想乘坐荷兰船横渡大西洋。
And the reason why people feel this is okay is basically because it's not just the Titanic that is seen as being unsinkable, but all ships of this caliber and size. Yeah. Later on when we, you know, in episode 324 of this series, when the Titanic has finally been hauled by the iceberg, a ship called the Carpathia comes and rescues a lot of the lifeboats and at the inquiry arthur rostron who was the captain of this ship he was asked about this issue of lifeboats you don't think it's terrible they didn't have enough on the titanic and he said it was fine he said the ships are built nowadays to be practically unsinkable what an ironic thing for him to have said after the event and each ship is supposed to be a lifeboat in
人们觉得这没问题的原因基本上是因为不仅泰坦尼克号被视为永不沉没，所有这种口径和规模的船只都被视为永不沉没。是的。后来当我们，你知道，在本系列的第324集，当泰坦尼克号最终被冰山撞击时，一艘叫卡帕西亚号（Carpathia）的船来营救了很多救生艇，在调查中，这艘船的船长亚瑟·罗斯特龙（Arthur Rostron）被问及救生艇的问题，你不觉得他们没有足够的救生艇很糟糕吗？他说没关系，他说现在的船只被建造得实际上是永不沉没的。他在事后说出这样的话是多么讽刺，而且每艘船都应该是一艘救生艇
itself so in a way the lifeboats are the equivalent of the life jackets on an aeroplane ultimately they do put life jackets on an aeroplane don't they yeah and you know there's the whistle for inflating or whatever it is it's like making the sound of the evil eye i mean it's not meant to be real it's just meant to reassure people yeah it. It's to reassure you. Realistically, you can take 10,000 flights. You're never going to leave that life jacket. That's how they think about the lifeboats. They just think they're there for rescuing people who've fallen overboard, or maybe particularly going to the aid of another ship that is itself in distress, and we will help them out with our lifeboats. That's what they're for. I think it's Ismay who said that after the Titanic disaster. That was the point of our lifeboats.
本身，所以某种程度上，救生艇相当于飞机上的救生衣。最终他们确实在飞机上放了救生衣，不是吗？是的，你知道，有充气的哨子之类的，这就像发出邪恶之眼的声音，我的意思是，它不是为了真实，它只是为了让人们放心。是的，它是为了让你放心。现实地说，你可以乘坐1万次航班。你永远不会用到那件救生衣。这就是他们对救生艇的看法。他们只是认为它们是为了营救落水的人，或者可能特别是在另一艘船遇险时去援助，我们会用我们的救生艇帮助他们。这就是它们的用途。我想是伊斯梅在泰坦尼克号灾难后说的。这就是我们救生艇的意义。
Of course, Tom, as lots of our listeners will be thinking, it's all very well to say that, but the fact that it did sink and that obviously there weren't enough lifeboats is a flaw in their health and safety thinking, I think it's fair to say. It is a flaw, yes. All right, so that's the backdrop to it. When we come back in the second half, let's look at the process by which it is built, launched and set sail and embarks on its transatlantic maiden voyage. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
当然，汤姆，正如我们许多听众会想的那样，那样说很好，但它确实沉没了，而且显然救生艇不够多，这是他们健康和安全思维中的一个缺陷，我认为可以公平地说。这是一个缺陷，是的。好吧，这就是背景。当我们下半场回来时，让我们看看它建造、下水、启航并开始其跨大西洋处女航的过程。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《历史余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are Titanic-ing and Dominic, let's get it launched.
这是您每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史余味》。我们正在谈论泰坦尼克号，多米尼克，让我们开始下水吧。
Sure. What's the process? Well, I know you like the naval terminology, don't you, Tom? Love it. They laid down the keel on the 31st of March, 1909. What's the keel? The keel is the bottom. Very good.
当然。过程是什么？嗯，我知道你喜欢海军术语，对吧，汤姆？喜欢。他们在1909年3月31日铺设了龙骨。什么是龙骨？龙骨是底部。非常好。
That's the bottom. And then it takes about two years to build, like the Olympic. So it's a big investment from the company. You know, you're building it a long time. And they're built next door to each other. So outside the Titanic Museum, the two, whatever it is, docks, where they build both the Olympic and the Titanic are next door to each other. And you can kind of trace the length. It's very, very powerful.
那是底部。然后建造大约需要两年时间，像奥林匹克号一样。所以这是公司的一笔大投资。你知道，你建造它需要很长时间。它们是挨着建造的。所以泰坦尼克博物馆外面，那两个，不管是什么，码头，建造奥林匹克号和泰坦尼克号的地方是挨着的。你可以追踪长度。这非常、非常震撼。
The three inches. Is it three inches that's difference between the two yeah size matters dominic it does so 26 months it takes to build and it's ready at the end of may 1911 so for people who know a lot about irish and british history it's being built during the period where it's all kicking off isn't it yeah politics and the sort of sectarian tension is becoming more and more intense. So on the 31st of May, the three characters that we talked about in episode one, Lord Pirrie from Harland and Wolfe, Bruce Ismay from White Star, and J. Pierbont Morgan from the holding company IMM, they are all there to see it.
三英寸。两艘船之间相差三英寸，是的，规模很重要，多米尼克。确实如此，所以建造需要26个月，1911年5月底准备就绪。所以对于那些非常了解爱尔兰和英国历史的人来说，它是在一切都开始动荡的时期建造的，不是吗？是的，政治和某种宗派紧张局势变得越来越激烈。所以在5月31日，我们在第一集中谈到的三个角色，哈兰德与沃尔夫的皮里勋爵、白星航运的布鲁斯·伊斯梅，以及控股公司IMM的J.皮尔庞特·摩根（J. Pierpont Morgan），他们都在那里见证了它。
So it's launched. Now they can get onto the interior and it takes them the best part, IMM. They are all there to see it. So it's launched. Now they can get onto the interior and it takes them the best part of a year. So until the end of March, 1912, fitting it out inside, making it as good as possible. And then on the 2nd of April, 1912, they're not going to hang around. They're going to go for the maiden voyage straight away. Well, why would they? Because they need to get their money back. So there are 12 hours of sea trials. This is standard. So they practice turning, reversing the ship, doing an emergency stop, all that kind of thing. Everything is fine. There's no recklessness. Nothing is wrong with it. So at seven o'clock that evening, the 2nd of April, 1912, comes back into belfast perfect it's all
所以它下水了。现在他们可以进入内部，这需要他们大部分时间，IMM。他们都在那里见证了它。所以它下水了。现在他们可以进入内部，这需要他们大部分时间。所以直到1912年3月底，在内部进行装修，尽可能做到最好。然后在1912年4月2日，他们不会拖延。他们会立即进行处女航。好吧，他们为什么要拖延呢？因为他们需要收回成本。所以有12个小时的海试。这是标准的。所以他们练习转向、倒船、进行紧急停车，所有这类事情。一切都很好。没有鲁莽。它没有任何问题。所以在1912年4月2日那天晚上七点，回到贝尔法斯特，完美，一切都
done the crew some of them come on board the people are going to sail it to southampton it takes basically two days to sail it round down the irish sea around the bottom of england to the port of southampton in hampshire Southampton has replaced Liverpool as the main British end point, hasn't it? Yes, it has. And we'll explain why in a second. So Southampton is the Edwardians' sort of port of choice. So it's in the south of England, just above the Isle of Wight. And it docks at berth 44 in Southampton.
完成了。船员，他们中的一些人上船，人们将把它航行到南安普敦，基本上需要两天时间把它绕过爱尔兰海，绕过英格兰底部到达汉普郡的南安普敦港。南安普敦已经取代利物浦成为主要的英国终点站，不是吗？是的，确实如此。我们稍后会解释原因。所以南安普敦是爱德华时代人们的首选港口。它位于英格兰南部，就在怀特岛上方。它停靠在南安普敦的44号泊位。
It's ready to take on the crew that will take it across to New York. And of course, his passengers. Extraordinary to think, Tom, that at this point, there are only 11 days to go until the Titanic sinks. Yeah, incredible. So all this, as we said, has overlapped.
它准备好迎接将带它横渡到纽约的船员。当然，还有它的乘客。想到这一点真是不可思议，汤姆，此时距离泰坦尼克号沉没只有11天了。是的，不可思议。所以这一切，正如我们所说，都有重叠。
And just on this issue, the overlap with the home rule crisis. So the Liberal government of Herbert Henry Asquith is preparing to introduce the third home rule bill for Ireland at the very moment that this is happening so Asquith will actually introduce that bill on the floor of the house of commons the day after the titanic sales from Southampton so as they're making the final preparations you know the last bits of fitting out the trials all that stuff people are holding military drills in the streets of belfast preparing for what they see as a possible civil war so it's against that background
关于这个问题，还有它与地方自治危机（Home Rule crisis）的重叠。赫伯特·亨利·阿斯奎斯（Herbert Henry Asquith）领导的自由党政府正准备在这一时刻为爱尔兰引入第三部地方自治法案。所以，就在泰坦尼克号从南安普敦启航的第二天，阿斯奎斯实际上就会在下议院提出该法案。因此，当人们在进行最后的准备工作，比如最后的装配、试航等等时，贝尔法斯特街头的人们正在举行军事演习，为他们眼中的可能爆发的内战做准备，所以这就是当时的背景。
that all this is happening and actually this is an important detail when it comes to the guy who runs the shipyard, Lord Pirrie. Lord Pirrie, as we said last time, is a very unusual being a supporter of the liberals and of home rule. And he actually books a hall in Belfast during the final months of the Titanic being in Belfast for Winston Churchill in his capacity as a radical firebrand. A liberal. Yeah, as a liberal. Yeah. To come and give a speech in favour of Home Rule. And there was tremendous controversy about this. They have to change the venue to a Celtic Park football ground,
这一切都发生在这种背景下，实际上，当谈到经营造船厂的人——皮里勋爵（Lord Pirrie）时，这是一个重要的细节。正如我们上次所说，皮里勋爵是一个非常不寻常的人，他是自由党和地方自治的支持者。在泰坦尼克号停留在贝尔法斯特的最后几个月里，他实际上为温斯顿·丘吉尔预订了一个大厅，以他作为激进煽动者的身份。一个自由党人。是的，作为一名自由党人。是的。来发表支持地方自治的演讲。这引起了巨大的争议。他们不得不将地点改到凯尔特公园足球场，
which is in the Catholic area. Churchill and Pirrie go through, and there are Protestants kind of jeering at them, shouting at them, throwing things and whatnot. Churchill sort of gets out relatively unscathed. But a couple of days later, Pirrie leaves to go back to England. And when he leaves at Larne, there are mobs pelting him with eggs and herrings and shouting traitor at him. He's only able to get on the ship under police protection. He goes back to England and he is cheered at a big liberal dinner. And Tom, you've got this detail, haven't you?
那是在天主教徒聚居区。丘吉尔和皮里走过去，新教徒们在那儿嘲笑他们，对他们大喊大叫，扔东西等等。丘吉尔算是相对安然无恙地离开了。但几天后，皮里动身回英国。当他在拉恩（Larne）离开时，暴徒们向他投掷鸡蛋和鲱鱼，并对他高喊“叛徒”。他只能在警察的保护下才得以登上船。他回到英国后，在一次大型自由党晚宴上受到了欢呼。汤姆，你有这个细节，对吧？
Yes. So I got sent this photograph by Nicholas Tate, very much a friend of the show who has interviewed us on BBC Ulster. And when I was in Belfast, gave me a wonderful tour. And he sent me this photo of anti-home rule slogans scrawled all over the keel of the Titanic, which had to be washed off, obviously, before the ship was launched. So the idea of the Titanic as a kind of billboard for Irish politics in 1912, I mean, I had no idea. No, it's fascinating, isn't it? Because when you think about it, many of those men who built that ship, who are painstakingly putting the finishing touches to what they regard as their greatest creation.
是的。所以我收到了尼古拉斯·泰特（Nicholas Tate）发来的这张照片，他是节目的好朋友，曾在BBC阿尔斯特电台采访过我们。当我在贝尔法斯特时，他带我进行了一次很棒的参观。他发给我这张照片，上面是潦草地写在泰坦尼克号龙骨上的反地方自治口号，显然在船下水之前必须把它们洗掉。所以，泰坦尼克号作为1912年爱尔兰政治的一种广告牌的想法，我是真的一点都不知道。不，这很迷人，不是吗？因为当你想到这一点时，那些建造那艘船的人，那些正在一丝不苟地为他们视为自己最伟大创造物进行最后润色的人。
They're the same men who are most active in the politics of the day. Who'll be signing up to Sir Edward Carson's paramilitary organisations. Yeah. Who may be after work, going to the Orange Lodge, drilling, talking about taking up arms, all of that kind of thing. It is fascinating. And this has an impact on Piri himself because two weeks, well, less than two weeks actually after this incident, he falls ill and he has to have a prostate operation. And who can say whether the stress or the pressure or whatever has an effect. But what that means is he will not sail on the maiden voyage of the Titanic.
他们正是那些在当时的政治中最活跃的人。他们会报名参加爱德华·卡森爵士（Sir Edward Carson）的准军事组织。是的。他们可能在下班后去橙色会所（Orange Lodge），进行操练，谈论拿起武器，所有这类事情。这太迷人了。这对皮里本人也有影响，因为在这次事件发生两周，实际上不到两周后，他病倒了，不得不接受前列腺手术。谁能说压力或紧张或其他什么是否有影响呢。但这意味着他将不会参加泰坦尼克号的处女航。
Very Kaiser Wilhelm behavior, Tom. He goes off to the regatta at Kiel instead, where he hobnobs with lots of German ship owners. But of course, as Richard Ebenport Hines says, if he had sailed on that voyage, either he would have died and he would have been the biggest name British fatality, or he would not have died and he would have been the biggest name British fatality, or he would not have died and he would have been the biggest scapegoat because he'd escaped. But as it is, it's another British person involved in this. Who does become the scapegoat. Bruce Ismay, who is also going to sail, who will play that role, as we will see. So the Titanic leaves Belfast. It leaves a city where there are huge crowds, demonstrations. The conservative leader,
汤姆，这表现得非常像威廉皇帝（Kaiser Wilhelm）。他反而去了基尔（Kiel）的帆船赛，在那里他与许多德国船主攀谈。但当然，正如理查德·埃本波特·海恩斯（Richard Ebenport Hines）所说，如果他参加了那次航行，要么他会死，他将成为最大牌的英国遇难者，要么他不会死，他将成为最大的替罪羊，因为他逃脱了。但事实是，这是另一个参与其中的英国人。他确实成为了替罪羊。布鲁斯·伊斯梅（Bruce Ismay），他也要参加航行，他将扮演那个角色，正如我们将要看到的那样。所以泰坦尼克号离开了贝尔法斯特。它离开了一个有大量人群、示威活动的城市。保守党领袖，
Bonalor, has gone over to Northern Ireland to review paramilitaries. Like a workman in the bounds of the Titanic, he is stoking the fires, isn't he, Dominic? Very good, Tom. Yes, he is. He's a fireman stoking the fires of sectarianism. Driving the United Kingdom towards the iceberg of potential civil war. Exactly so. But anyway, the Titanic has left all that behind because the Titanic is now in Southampton. And Southampton, as you were saying, has an interesting history itself. So Southampton had not been the primary transatlantic port for the Victorians, but again, it has been transformed by capitalist modernity because the London Southwestern Railway had bought the Southampton Dock Company in 1892 for £1.3 million because the railway people want to transform the port to London's port of choice.
博纳·劳（Bonar Law），已经前往北爱尔兰视察准军事部队。多米尼克，他就像泰坦尼克号里的工人一样，正在煽风点火，不是吗？说得好，汤姆。是的，他是。他是一个煽动宗派主义之火的消防员。将联合王国推向潜在内战的冰山。正是如此。但无论如何，泰坦尼克号已经把这一切抛在脑后了，因为泰坦尼克号现在在南安普敦。正如你所说，南安普敦本身也有着有趣的历史。所以南安普敦并不是维多利亚时代主要的跨大西洋港口，但同样，它已经被资本主义现代性所改变，因为伦敦西南铁路公司在1892年以130万英镑收购了南安普敦码头公司，因为铁路公司的人想把这个港口改造成伦敦的首选港口。
So they poured money into the port. Of course, it's closer to London than Liverpool was. It's also closer to the continent, isn't it? Yeah. So you can get to France really quickly. So yes, you can pop over to Cherbourg where they've likewise really developed it. You can't actually land in Cherbourg, but you can send out little boats that will bring people from Cherbourg. Exactly so. So in 1907, White Star, Bruce Ismay's company, had scrapped its Atlantic liner service from Liverpool and moved it to Southampton.
所以他们向港口投入了资金。当然，它比利物浦更靠近伦敦。它也更靠近欧洲大陆，不是吗？是的。所以你可以很快到达法国。所以是的，你可以跳到瑟堡（Cherbourg），他们同样在那里进行了真正的开发。你实际上不能在瑟堡登陆，但你可以派出小船，把人们从瑟堡接过来。正是如此。所以1907年，白星航运公司（White Star），布鲁斯·伊斯梅的公司，已经取消了从利物浦出发的跨大西洋班轮服务，并将其转移到了南安普敦。
Although it's interesting, isn't it, that Liverpool is still the name that is painted on the back of… Yes. Yeah, there's a sentimental attachment to Liverpool indeed, as we'll come on to. Some of the crew, they've moved to Southampton, but they're originally from Liverpool. In the James Cameron film, you know, the bit where it gets upended, you see the great turbines and you see the name Titanic, and then you see Liverpool just before it plunges into the icy depths. So the last thing you might see was the word Liverpool. It's not ideal branding for the city. There you go. So yes, it's got Southampton, which is, you know, the new hub for the kind of transatlantic trade. So it will go Southampton, as you said, Tom, Cherbourg and Normandy. Then it will go across to Ireland, to the port of Queenstown, which is known today as Cove. And then it will go from there to New York.
虽然很有趣，不是吗，利物浦仍然是漆在船尾的名字……是的。是的，确实有一种对利物浦的怀旧之情，正如我们稍后会谈到的。一些船员，他们搬到了南安普敦，但他们最初来自利物浦。在詹姆斯·卡梅隆的电影里，你知道，船身倾覆的那一段，你看到巨大的涡轮机，你看到“泰坦尼克号”这个名字，然后在它沉入冰冷的深渊之前，你看到了“利物浦”。所以你最后可能看到的就是“利物浦”这个词。这对这座城市来说不是理想的品牌宣传。就是这样。所以是的，它有南安普敦，你知道，这是跨大西洋贸易的新中心。所以它会走南安普敦，正如你所说的，汤姆，瑟堡和诺曼底。然后它会穿过海峡去爱尔兰，去皇后镇（Queenstown）港口，也就是今天所知的科夫（Cove）。然后它会从那里去纽约。
And while it's in Southampton, the first thing they obviously need to do is they load it with all the stuff. So much stuff. So much stuff. So you read those stats, Tom, on the length of the ship and all that stuff. Yeah. But to me, it's this that is actually mind-boggling. Yeah. 800 bundles of asparagus. Yeah.
当它在南安普敦时，他们显然需要做的第一件事就是装载所有的东西。太多的东西了。太多的东西了。所以你读了那些统计数据，汤姆，关于船的长度和所有那些东西。是的。但对我来说，这才是令人难以置信的。是的。800捆芦笋。是的。
16,000 lemons. 1,000 pounds of grapes. What would 2,500 pounds of sausages even look like? And imagine how many they have on the German ships. That's true. Some of it actually seems quite, so 1,500 bottles of wine, that seems inadequate to me. Yeah. Yeah.
16,000个柠檬。1,000磅葡萄。2,500磅香肠看起来会是什么样？想象一下他们在德国船上有多少。那是真的。其中一些实际上看起来相当，所以1,500瓶葡萄酒，这对我来说似乎不够。是的。是的。
Only 12 mops. Yes. I would have more mops. Yes. And one potato peeler that Bruce Ismay has insisted be thrown in. But then, you know, 400 sugar tongs, 8,000 tumblers, 50 boxes of grapefruit, 40 tons of potatoes, 6,000 pounds of bacon and ham.
只有12把拖把。是的。我会多要些拖把。是的。还有一把布鲁斯·伊斯梅坚持要扔进去的土豆削皮器。但你知道，400个糖夹，8,000个平底玻璃杯，50箱葡萄柚，40吨土豆，6,000磅培根和火腿。
100 grape scissors. All of this stuff. So all of this stuff is loaded. And then, of course, they have the crew. So the crew, this is the most high profile, the most exciting voyage in White Star's history. So they want their very best. Yeah, the creme de la creme.
100把葡萄剪。所有这些东西。所以所有这些东西都被装上了船。然后，当然，他们有了船员。所以船员，这是白星航运史上最引人注目、最令人兴奋的航行。所以他们想要他们最好的。是的，精英中的精英。
Tip top. Yeah. So they've got 892 crewmen. 700 of them are from Southampton. And of those, just under half are from Southampton originally. They're from Hampshire. But quite a lot of them are people who have moved from Merseyside, who have moved down from Liverpool when White Star changed the route. So actually, when the disaster happens, Liverpool is a stricken city in the same way that Southampton is or New York is or Belfast is.
顶尖的。是的。所以他们有892名船员。其中700人来自南安普敦。而在这些人中，不到一半最初来自南安普敦。他们来自汉普郡。但其中相当多的人是从默西塞德郡搬来的，当白星航运改变航线时，他们从利物浦搬了下来。所以实际上，当灾难发生时，利物浦是一个受灾城市，就像南安普敦、纽约或贝尔法斯特一样。
Almost all of them are British, with the exception of some of the restaurant staff are Italians. So this is the kind of golden age of Italian people moving to Britain, restaurants, ice cream, coffee, all of that kind of thing. So there's more than 40 Italian restaurant staff who actually die in the disaster. And the way the crew works is it's divided into three. So there's the deck department, there's the engine department, and there's the stewards department. And the deck crew are the main officers, there's a surgeon, there are storekeepers, there's two window cleaners. A lamp trimmer. A lamp trimmer, yeah. But also there's a masseuse, a fish cook, then there's the stewards. They have it quite tough, don't they? Very kind of brutal working hours, kind of 16 hours a day. So there's a brilliant account of it by one of the stewardesses who survived the Titanic, Violet Jessop, which is a brilliant account of kind of below stairs
几乎所有人都是英国人，除了部分餐厅员工是意大利人。所以这是意大利人移居英国的黄金时代，餐馆、冰淇淋、咖啡，所有这类事情。所以有超过40名意大利餐厅员工在灾难中丧生。船员的工作方式分为三部分：甲板部门、轮机部门和乘务部门。甲板船员是主要官员，有一名外科医生，有仓库管理员，有两名窗户清洁工。一名灯具修理工。一名灯具修理工，是的。但还有一名按摩师，一名鱼类厨师，然后是乘务员。他们过得很辛苦，不是吗？非常残酷的工作时间，每天大约16小时。所以泰坦尼克号的幸存者之一，维奥莱特·杰索普（Violet Jessop），对此有一个精彩的描述，这是关于泰坦尼克号楼下生活的一个精彩叙述。
on the Titanic. Well, it's like being a domestic servant, isn't it? It is, yeah. I mean, they have to show unstinting deference, certainly to the first class passengers. Apparently the American millionaires thought that they were excellent because they didn't seem surly. Unlike American stewards who apparently were very surly and would make faces at you behind your back. So that's a nice kind of shift, isn't it? Yeah, that's nice. Because now it's our plucky British service workers who are famous for being rude. Yes. Golly. Yeah, that is a change. And then you have the engine room. I mean, everybody basically says the engine room is a total and utter inferno. It is hell on earth.
嗯，这就像是当一名家仆，不是吗？是的，确实。我的意思是，他们必须表现出毫无保留的顺从，当然是对头等舱乘客。显然，美国百万富翁认为他们很棒，因为他们看起来并不粗鲁。不像美国乘务员，他们显然非常粗鲁，会在你背后对你做鬼脸。所以这是一个很好的转变，不是吗？是的，那很好。因为现在是我们勇敢的英国服务人员以粗鲁而闻名。是的。天哪。是的，那是一个变化。然后你有轮机舱。我的意思是，每个人基本上都说轮机舱是一个彻头彻尾的炼狱。那是人间地狱。
They have greasers, don't they? Imagine being a greaser. Yeah. There are 280 men in total. And people who ever go down there say, God, you don't want to go down there. Well, there's a Cunard officer, isn't there? Yes. A man called James Bissett, who says that no man have ever had such hard and brutalizing work as the firemen and the trimmers and the big coal burning steamers in the early years of the 20th century i felt pity for them as i saw them coming off watch and trudging wearily to their quarters utterly done in sweat squelching in their boots their faces blackened with coal dust and streaked with sweat had a dull animal-like look and they seldom smiled it was killing work
他们有加油工，不是吗？想象一下当一名加油工。是的。总共有280人。去过那里的人都说，天哪，你不想去那里。嗯，有一名卡纳德（Cunard）公司的官员，不是吗？是的。一个叫詹姆斯·比塞特（James Bissett）的人，他说，在20世纪初，没有哪个人像大型燃煤轮船上的消防员和修剪工那样从事如此艰苦和残酷的工作。当我看到他们下班，疲惫地拖着脚步回到宿舍时，我为他们感到难过，他们完全精疲力竭，汗水在靴子里发出吱吱声，他们的脸被煤灰熏黑，被汗水冲刷出条纹，有一种迟钝的动物般的表情，他们很少微笑，那是杀人的工作。
yeah people sometimes say it's like being a coal miner, but you're on a ship and it's just there forever. Yes, naturally, a lot of the firemen who come from Belfast, people hate doing long stints. So the people who come from Belfast to Southampton then don't want to go from Southampton to New York and they end up being replaced by new firemen. I mean, not all of them, obviously, but some of them. So a lot of the crew have come over from Belfast, not all of them. But when they get on the ship, they all say, amazing, what a brilliant ship this is, very exciting. And they write to friends and things, she is an improvement on Olympic. She's a wonderful ship. She's the latest thing in shipbuilding. This ship is going to be a good deal better than the Olympic, at least I think so,
是的，人们有时说这就像当煤矿工人，但你在船上，它就永远在那里。是的，自然地，许多来自贝尔法斯特的消防员，人们讨厌做长时间的工作。所以那些从贝尔法斯特来到南安普敦的人，不想从南安普敦去纽约，他们最终被新的消防员取代了。我的意思是，显然不是所有人，但其中一些。所以很多船员是从贝尔法斯特过来的，不是全部。但当他们上船时，他们都说，太棒了，这是一艘多么出色的船，非常令人兴奋。他们写信给朋友等等，她说这是对奥林匹克号（Olympic）的改进。她是一艘很棒的船。她是造船业的最新成果。这艘船会比奥林匹克号好得多，至少我是这么认为的，
steadier and everything. So the only thing that worries them is it's so big they'll get lost and there's two officers in particular that have stuck in i think the world's imagination one of them whose life story is just mind-blowing is this guy charles herbert lightoller yeah so he's second officer lots of people will have seen more than one fictional representation of him because he is Mr. Dawson in Dunkirk. Really? You know, the Mark Rylance character. Did you not know that, Tom? No, I did not know that. So you know Dunkirk? Yeah. You know Mark Rylance? You know his little
更平稳等等。所以唯一让他们担心的是它太大了，他们会迷路，特别是两名官员，我认为他们留在了世界的想象中，其中一个人的生活故事简直令人震惊，就是这个叫查尔斯·赫伯特·莱托勒（Charles Herbert Lightoller）的家伙。是的，他是二副，很多人会看到不止一个关于他的虚构形象，因为他是《敦刻尔克》里的道森先生（Mr. Dawson）。真的吗？你知道，马克·里朗斯（Mark Rylance）那个角色。你不知道吗，汤姆？不，我不知道。所以你知道《敦刻尔克》？是的。你知道马克·里朗斯？你知道他的小
boat? Yeah. And he goes out. This is Charles Lightoller. Is it? Charles Lightoller's boat was called the Sundowner. Goodness. He took it across and he brought back 140 men from Dunkirk. And he managed not to sink this time. And this time he didn't sink. Exactly. Exactly.
船吗？是的。他出去了。这就是查尔斯·莱托勒。是吗？查尔斯·莱托勒的船叫“日落者号”（Sundowner）。天哪。他把它开过去，从敦刻尔克带回了140人。这次他设法没有沉没。这次他没有沉没。正是如此。正是如此。
Mr. Dawson is modelled on him. He's the most senior officer who survives, isn't he? He is indeed. And so that's why he's remembered. He is indeed. And of course, his handling of the lifeboats, as we will discover, becomes very controversial. Yes, but not perhaps as controversial as the senior officer on board the Titanic, who is Captain Edward Smith, who is an absolute icon for the White Star, isn't he?
道森先生是以他为原型的。他是幸存的最高级官员，不是吗？他确实是。所以这就是为什么他被人们记住。他确实是。当然，正如我们将要发现的那样，他对救生艇的处理变得非常有争议。是的，但也许不像泰坦尼克号上的高级官员爱德华·史密斯（Edward Smith）船长那样有争议，他是白星航运的绝对偶像，不是吗？
He has basically captained all their steamships on their first voyages. And basically they feel, well, if he's at the helm, everything's going to be great. Nothing can go wrong. So he's in the film. Is he Bernard Hill? Is he Théoden? He is. Yes. Yeah, he's Bernard Hill.
他基本上指挥了他们所有蒸汽船的首次航行。基本上他们觉得，嗯，如果他在掌舵，一切都会很棒。什么都不会出错。所以他在电影里。他是伯纳德·希尔（Bernard Hill）吗？他是希优顿（Théoden）吗？他是。是的。是的，他是伯纳德·希尔。
So he was from Staffordshire. He was from Hanley in the Potteries. He'd actually worked in the Potteries at the Etruria Forge. He had captained 17 of White Star's ships, sailed for a total of 2 million miles for them. He's very well paid. He's paid £1,250 a year with a bonus of £1,000 a year if he brings the ships back in good order. So to give people an idea, I would say that's about £800,000 and then the bonus. So he could be looking to earn more than a million pounds a year in today's money.
所以他来自斯塔福德郡。他来自陶器产区的汉利（Hanley）。他实际上在陶器产区的伊特鲁里亚锻造厂（Etruria Forge）工作过。他指挥过17艘白星航运的船只，为他们航行了总共200万英里。他薪水很高。他每年获得1,250英镑的报酬，如果他能让船只保持良好状态，每年还有1,000英镑的奖金。所以给人们一个概念，我会说那大约是80万英镑，然后是奖金。所以他今天的收入可能超过每年一百万英镑。
And he looks like Captain Birdseye. He's got a kind of white beard. He's kind of stout. Yeah. He's a kind of jolly man. He looks as he should. Yeah. Yeah, you trust him.
他看起来像“鸟眼船长”（Captain Birdseye）。他留着白胡子。他有点胖。是的。他是一个快乐的人。他看起来就该是那样。是的。是的，你信任他。
He's absolutely as he should be. Ho, ho, ho. Yeah. Welcome to the Titanic. Welcome. So he's a kind of living embodiment of white star's commitment to service and safety and on that note he's interviewed by a newspaper in 1907 yeah and he says i never saw a wreck and i have never been wrecked nor have i ever been in any predicament that threatened to
他绝对是他该有的样子。呵呵呵。是的。欢迎来到泰坦尼克号。欢迎。所以他是白星航运对服务和安全承诺的活生生的化身，关于这一点，他在1907年接受了一家报纸的采访，是的，他说，我从未见过沉船，我也从未遭遇过海难，我也从未处于任何威胁到
end in disaster and i know that he didn't speak like that because he wasn't a pirate he was from staffordshire tom say he might have sounded like you know how you should do you're not power the great captain who doesn't let things happen that's not how it's daffodil people he would say well i never saw a wreck and i've never been wrecked nor have i never been in any predicament that threatened to end in disaster that's how he would speak like jack davenport the executive producer of the rest is history yeah so yeah he doesn't even think it would be fair to say, because his principle is that if nothing happens, then it's been a good voyage. And obviously that is correct. However, Dominic, however, the truth is, and this will be a point made by the American
以灾难告终的困境中。我知道他不是那样说话的，因为他不是海盗，他来自斯塔福德郡，汤姆。说他可能听起来像你知道你应该怎么做，你不是那个不让事情发生的伟大船长，那不是斯塔福德郡人的说话方式，他会说，嗯，我从未见过沉船，我也从未遭遇过海难，我也从未处于任何威胁到以灾难告终的困境中，他会那样说话，就像《历史余味》（The Rest Is History）的执行制片人杰克·达文波特（Jack Davenport）一样。是的，所以是的，他甚至不认为那样说是公平的，因为他的原则是，如果什么都没发生，那就是一次好的航行。显然这是正确的。然而，多米尼克，然而，事实是，这将在泰坦尼克号沉没后成为美国媒体提出的一个观点，
press in the wake of the sinking of the Titanic, he should have been retired before he took the captaincy of the Titanic because eight months prior to the sailing of the Titanic, he had been involved in not one but two accidents. So the previous September, he'd been captaining the Olympic, the Titanic's sister ship, and he had rammed the Olympic into a British cruiser, HMS Hawk. Everybody makes mistakes, Tom, come on. And then in February, so that's only a couple of months before the sailing of the Titanic, he had driven the Olympic over a ship that had been wrecked and was kind of submerged under the sea and lost the propeller blade. So that's not really a good omen. And when he takes Titanic out of Southampton, across the channel towards Cherbourg, while he's Titanic out of Southampton across the channel towards Cherbourg,
在担任泰坦尼克号船长之前，他本应该退休的，因为在泰坦尼克号启航前八个月，他卷入了不止一起，而是两起事故。所以前一年九月，他指挥着泰坦尼克号的姊妹船奥林匹克号，他把奥林匹克号撞向了一艘英国巡洋舰，HMS霍克号（HMS Hawk）。每个人都会犯错，汤姆，拜托。然后在二月，也就是泰坦尼克号启航前几个月，他把奥林匹克号开过了一艘已经沉没并淹没在海下的船，丢失了螺旋桨叶片。所以这真的不是一个好兆头。当他把泰坦尼克号开出南安普敦，穿过海峡前往瑟堡时，当他把泰坦尼克号开出南安普敦，穿过海峡前往瑟堡时，
while he's coming out of Southampton, he very, very narrowly avoids crashing into an American liner, the New York. See, I thought you were going to mention this because I think, doesn't Frances Wilson mention this? She does, yes. And I think this is too harsh because actually, interestingly, not only is this the period of Home Rule, the Home Rule controversy in Britain, but it's a period of enormous trade union unrest. And there's a coal strike in Southampton that means that all these other ships are stuck. They are, as it were, grounded. And as he sails, the New York gets sort of sucked in by his wash and almost crashes into him. And he very skillfully, Tom, steers away from the New York. And this time manages not to crash into a Royal Navy frigate or lose a propeller. I think he's a tremendous captain.
当他出来时，他非常、非常惊险地避免了撞上一艘美国班轮，纽约号（New York）。看，我以为你会提到这个，因为我想，弗朗西丝·威尔逊（Frances Wilson）不是提到了吗？她确实提到了，是的。我认为这太苛刻了，因为实际上，有趣的是，这不仅是英国地方自治时期，地方自治争议时期，而且是一个巨大的工会动荡时期。南安普敦发生了煤炭罢工，这意味着所有其他船只都停滞了。它们可以说是搁浅了。当他航行时，纽约号被他的尾流吸了进去，差点撞上他。他非常熟练地，汤姆，避开了纽约号。这一次设法没有撞上皇家海军护卫舰或丢失螺旋桨。我认为他是一位了不起的船长。
And I would happily take my chances with Captain Smith. Okay. But a counter view, Francis Wilson, like his first class passengers, Smith was pampered, celebrated and overconfident. I think she's only saying that because he's saying that's Titanic. I think that's too harsh. So anyway, they're about to leave. We will come to the passengers next time because they really have some extraordinary stories. They're in the most amazing range of rogues, rascals. It's like a novel, isn't it? Absolutely.
我会很高兴地和史密斯船长一起冒险。好吧。但反面观点，弗朗西丝·威尔逊说，像他的头等舱乘客一样，史密斯被宠坏了，被吹捧，而且过于自信。我想她这么说只是因为他在说那是泰坦尼克号。我认为这太苛刻了。所以无论如何，他们即将离开。我们下次会谈到乘客，因为他们确实有一些非凡的故事。他们是令人惊叹的流氓、无赖。这就像一部小说，不是吗？绝对是。
It's like a Victorian novel with a whole, you know, the whole of society is present in a single space. There's migrants from Armenia, from Lebanon. There are plutocrats, you know, incredible. Yeah, amazing. But let's just end with the issue of how much this whole story is an inevitable one. You know, a kind of Greek tragedy, as it were, or whether it's purely an example of chance in history. The way you tell the story is determined by how you think history works.
这就像一部维多利亚时代的小说，整个社会都出现在一个单一的空间里。有来自亚美尼亚、黎巴嫩的移民。有财阀，你知道，不可思议。是的，太棒了。但让我们以整个故事在多大程度上是不可避免的问题来结束吧。你知道，一种希腊悲剧，或者它纯粹是历史中偶然性的一个例子。你讲述故事的方式取决于你认为历史是如何运作的。
Yeah. And I think there is a lovely story which gives an example of how chance matters. I say lovely story, not lovely for everybody. so before they sail on the 10th of april the crew particularly the guys who work in the inferno they all go out and they get absolutely wasted so they have gone for a last pub crawl and this is what they always do isn't it because their life is so hard yeah that when you're on shore you just get as drunk as you can and the deal is they go for this great pub crawl through all the dockside pubs very hard environment, I imagine. And then they have to be back by midday.
是的。我认为有一个可爱的故事，它给出了偶然性如何重要的例子。我说可爱的故事，对每个人来说都不可爱。所以他们在4月10日启航之前，船员，特别是那些在炼狱里工作的人，他们都出去喝得烂醉如泥。所以他们去进行了最后一次酒吧巡游，这就是他们总是做的，不是吗？因为他们的生活太艰难了，是的，当你在岸上时，你只是尽可能地喝醉，交易是他们去所有码头酒吧进行这次伟大的酒吧巡游，非常艰难的环境，我想。然后他们必须在中午前回来。
And a guy, a fireman called John Podesta, later on, after the voyage was over, he described how he and his friend, William Nutbean, had gone to the Newcastle Hotel, a few pints. They went onto a pub called The Grapes. And they met three brothers called the slade brothers who worked with them and at 10 50 cutting it very fine they rush back to get to the ship and they're going towards the docks when they have to cross a railway line and a passenger train is coming towards them and podesta and nut bean run across the railway line to get to the docks because they don't want to be late. The Slade brothers hang back to let the train pass. The train is much longer than they expect. So they're waiting and waiting. The train finally goes. They cross the tracks and they get
一个叫约翰·波德斯塔（John Podesta）的消防员，后来，航行结束后，他描述了他和他的朋友威廉·纳特比恩（William Nutbean）是如何去纽卡斯尔酒店（Newcastle Hotel）喝了几品脱。他们去了一家叫“葡萄”（The Grapes）的酒吧。他们遇到了三个叫斯莱德兄弟（Slade brothers）的人，他们和他们一起工作，在10点50分，时间非常紧迫，他们冲回去赶船，当他们走向码头时，他们必须穿过一条铁路线，一列客运列车正向他们驶来，波德斯塔和纳特比恩跑过铁路线去码头，因为他们不想迟到。斯莱德兄弟停下来让火车通过。火车比他们预期的要长得多。所以他们等啊等。火车终于走了。他们穿过轨道，到达了
down to the docks. Of course, they're now delayed a little bit. And as they run, they're now running to get there and the gangway is being swung aside and they shout at the officer in charge, sixth officer, who's a guy called Moody. And they say, we're here, we're here, we're here, let us on. And he says, no, you're too late. You're unreliable. You can't be trusted. And there were always people hanging around standby, hoping to get, you know, cause this is a time when people are desperate for work. So they're hoping to be taken on. And he gestures and he says to the standby, you guys come on instead. And the standby crew who were replacing these guys who waited for the train are Richard
码头。当然，他们现在被耽误了一点。当他们跑的时候，他们现在正跑着去那里，舷梯正被移开，他们对负责的官员大喊，六副，一个叫穆迪（Moody）的家伙。他们说，我们在这儿，我们在这儿，我们在这儿，让我们上去。他说，不，你们太晚了。你们不可靠。你们不能被信任。总有人在周围待命，希望能得到，你知道，因为这是一个人们渴望工作的时代。所以他们希望被录用。他做手势，对候补人员说，你们这些家伙上来代替。那些取代这些等火车的人的候补船员是理查德·
Hosgood, Alfred Gere, Harry Witt, Leonard Kinsler, and two men, one called Lloyd and one called Black. We don't have their first names. And that stand-in crew who are only there because of that train all died five days later. So if that train had been a minute delayed or had been a little bit shorter, those men who died would have lived. Yeah. Okay. So everyone is boarded at Southampton. Soon they'll be boarding at Cherbourg. They'll be touching at Queenstown and then off into the vast expanse of the Atlantic. And that, Dominic, is where we will be in our next episode, where we look at the incredible
霍斯古德（Richard Hosgood）、阿尔弗雷德·吉尔（Alfred Gere）、哈里·威特（Harry Witt）、伦纳德·金斯勒（Leonard Kinsler），还有两个人，一个叫劳埃德（Lloyd），一个叫布莱克（Black）。我们没有他们的名字。那些仅仅因为那列火车才在那里的候补船员，五天后都死了。所以如果那列火车晚了一分钟，或者短了一点，那些死去的人就会活着。是的。好吧。每个人都在南安普敦登船了。很快他们将在瑟堡登船。他们将在皇后镇停靠，然后进入大西洋的广阔空间。多米尼克，这就是我们下一集要讲的地方，我们将看看泰坦尼克号上令人难以置信的
array of people who are on board the Titanic. So if you're a member of the Rest Is History Club, you can accompany us on that voyage right away. If you are not a member, I'm afraid if you're down in the steerage, you'll have to wait until whenever Theo in his wisdom decides to bring out the next episode. So you may as well just join the club. And on that bombshell, we'll see you next time. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix
人群。所以如果你是《历史余味》俱乐部的成员，你可以马上陪我们进行那次航行。如果你不是会员，恐怕如果你在三等舱，你将不得不等到西奥（Theo）以他的智慧决定推出下一集的时候。所以你还不如加入俱乐部。带着这个重磅炸弹，我们下次见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们一起主持《娱乐余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment），这是你每周的固定节目
of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched
娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了
our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。